you
yeah this is another thing which is I
think in science it was this morning the
speeches by the politicians were quite
telling
I mean if children arm up because
they're good at school you can see why
sorry female scientist especially a
successful are not do not have a social
a better standing and on this on the
other hand I mean people suspect that
there might not be good mothers or there
might not be good people also so it's
not attractive socially from the society
it's not really attractive to be
successful sorry female scientist so
I've sometimes think why should I talk
young women into being a scientist if
they didn't end up being sort of this
light or not accepted by their
contemporaries and so it's a tricky
business actually
you